let us understand mutually exclusive
events with another example let us
consider one throw of a fair dice these
are the six possible outcomes at one
throw you have to get one of these let
us consider two events a and B and
understand if they are mutually
exclusive or not event a is getting an
even number an event B is getting an odd
number remember we have to consider just
one throw assume we get a two at the
first throw it is even and not odd at
the second throw we get a 5 so it is odd
and not even this means that if we get
an odd number we know that it is not
even and if we get an even number
it cannot be odd these two events cannot
occur together and are hence mutually
exclusive events now let's look at
another case say event a is getting an
odd number and event B is getting a
number less than four are these events
mutually exclusive let's see if we get a
one then we can see that it's an odd
number as well as a number less than
four it's the same if we get a three
these two events can happen together
which tells us that they are not
mutually exclusive
many get confused between independent
and mutually exclusive events if you are
one among those just remember these two
simple things two events are independent
if they are not related that is the
outcome of one does not affect the other
they are totally unrelated and two
events are mutually exclusive if they
cannot occur together
if one event occurs the other just
cannot occur so yes an event cannot be
independent and mutually exclusive at
the same time because if they're
independent they may occur together and
if they are mutually exclusive one event
be dependent on the other that is if one
occurs the other one will not occur